these are bananas obviously they're from
Trader Joe's today they cost 19 cents
each and about 25 years ago bananas at
Trader Joe's cost 19 cents as of 2020
Trader Joe's gross average sales per
square foot was more than double those
of other major grocery store chains and
it's been ranked the highest rated
grocery store for customer satisfaction
so how does Trader Joe's manage to keep
prices low while out competing
traditional grocery stores by selling
fewer products
this is the economics of Trader Joe's
Trader Joe's stores are smaller and they
tend to carry fewer items and the vast
majority of what they sell is private
label
when the store first opened in 1967
Trader Joe's founder Joe colombe
emphasized stocking products that were
unconventional to Shoppers at the time
like Dijon mustard and granola
in 1979 Trader Joe's was bought by the
German discount grocery store chain Aldi
Nord and today Trader Joe's has built
its image around selling trendy quirky
and seasonal items orange chicken
pasta sauce from Trader Joe's it helps
with fueling the experience for
customers people can go and kind of feel
like they're discovering something new
and these products have created a large
and loyal customer fan base I went to
Trader Joe's and I accidentally got I
got way too much stuff of course I love
Trader Joe's its popularity on social
media is helpful for the company because
Trader Joe's doesn't do a lot of
advertising
actually the grocery store doesn't do a
lot of things that other grocery stores
do there's no loyalty program no online
shopping platform and no Deli counter
still the Trader Joe's fan base is
strong and they are dedicated they are
Mega fans people will sell Trader Joe's
products on places like eBay for a much
higher price tag than what you would
find at the stores Trader Joe's smaller
selection can make the in-store shopping
experience more efficient for customers
according to psychologist and Professor
Barry Schwartz for example instead of
having to pick between many different
brands of tomato sauce at a conventional
grocery store
customers at Trader Joe's can quickly
select one from its more limited options
by selling a small selection of house
Brands Trader Joe's can control its own
supply chain which it says brings down
prices Trader Joe's items tend to be
cheaper because they buy directly from
producers and manufacturers whenever
they can so this Cuts costs that would
typically go to the middleman and the
company says they are able to pass that
along to Shoppers Trader Joe's says it
buys in bulk and often pays for items up
front whenever possible from suppliers
this all helps lower prices the grocery
store chain also says it pays for some
products like Dijon mustard in local
currency so if the currency fluctuates
Trader Joe's takes on the risk not the
supplier and by assuming the risk Trader
Joe's says it can negotiate better
prices with suppliers this control roll
over its products and supply chain means
Trader Joe's can easily add and remove
items from its shelves
one of the unique things about Trader
Joe's is they're constantly changing
their shelves if products aren't selling
as well as they thought they would they
removed them from their shelves to make
room for something better some grocery
stores charge Brands various marketing
fees to stock products but Trader Joe's
says it only makes money when customers
make a purchase
so according to Trader Joe's this
incentivizes it to only stock products
that customers like from JoJo's sandwich
cookies to Kung Pao chicken there isn't
really another chain that does what they
do there are other Discounters that sell
for cheaper but you're not going to find
the Innovation and and the fun products
there the traditional grocery stores
have tried to go that route but
Trader Joe's is Trader Joe's
[Music]
foreign